welcome to this video plate FM memento
yeah recently played him but i forgot to
the game what did i do in this game I
don't really know I have a feeling that
it was a slob as well but I don't really
know don't remember okay this is one of
those games where a win gives me the
all-time high again so kind of a special
situation and not a situation we have
you doing too well I tend to screw up
those situations but ok let's see we got
him it started as a sloth but with e 69
pt7 it very much looks like classical
Queens gambit mmm ok seems he's up to
seems he wants to play in the style of
the Cambridge Springs with Queen a5
interesting way to go it's important
though that h6 Bishop h4 was inserted so
I'm not in a huge I'm not in such a huge
trouble with this Bishop there ok
probably just this one that looks quite
normal yeah this is interesting and
maybe even even age 5 comes into
consideration no he just takes it
interesting ok
hmm interesting how do i go here maybe
just cancels it looks tempting to try to
use the rook on the edge file but i'm
not sure about this i mean if i want to
lose use the rook on the edge farm I
have to happen sorry I have to do
something with my king only one yeah if
I was actually bit tricky he has g4 I
didn't look at that move at all hmm
okay always doing something completely
different c5 interesting
okay I can just take keep it keep it
simple yeah maybe do that it sounds
really simplistic way to play but ok my
development is quite nice so just uh put
this here on Bishop g7 I have Bishop
your form maybe Bishop h7 is also an
idea okay so avoiding that Queen Maya if
i move the Queen you will take be too
that's a bit uncomfortable huh oh it's
difficult I mean I cannot really trade
Queens then be 2 and H was hanging ha
bit awkward
okay I have to give up the beep on there
is nothing else I can now see five
getting in this Queenie for idea for for
starters he has f5 to to to try to
defend that but point is I have to be
active here and trying to do something
with his King position possibly and my
better development let's see I'm scaring
them I cannot go rook see one
unfortunately and Queenie for is going
f5 f5
yeah maybe still I have to provoke some
weaknesses um Queen III yeah possibly
five young ms then is coming okay so
Quincy five I have to go Bishop c4 and
play for this compensation I really have
some compensation here it's not just two
points down on or simply a technical
task but it's not ideal but i think the
other continuations were the worse yeah
where I'm clinging passively and some
kind of endgame this is ok checking e6
and okay so he wants to go e5 this is
certainly not a bad idea but i have luke
t five so I'm kind of okay after if I've
I can also just take the endgame is not
bad at all if he trades everything off
on e5 okay he's starting to his his his
he's willing now to give material back
Bishop is six rook e8 unfortunately take
here ok i will take i will take so
Bishop d7 maybe looks a bit strange now
it may be have not not sure I have to be
a bit quicker here oh I didn't see that
one coming at all hmm not good
hmm oh that's it's bad okay Bishop a 60
why do I play I really play bad layer I
really play badly in those situations
where it's about all-time highs push
away six and I'm done blah ok didn't see
that one I go rook see one now ok let's
take further that's simpler look see one
what is he doing their hooks into or
what cheek and a tee time I'll ok
getting a pawn back
k check for my chest six if he goes to
g8 oh you just take it haha I really
don't know what I'm doing in those games
it's so embarrassing it's so bad it was
even it was a good position I by the way
it was quite okay and I just didn't see
that he could take it okay why okay it
was very young I mean he missed Bishop
86 pretty simple move actually yeah
Bishop 86 and I'm come on don't screw up
this now Bishop a6 just winning yeah
that was that was a big problem I mean I
was okay in this position I just have to
play it better let's see yeah you
suggest Luke see one after you five yeah
it's nothing nothing in particular um
mr. Ezra c2 I thought I ok that's a
point that's a pointer yeah that's
better yeah it was a very bad game
anyway i blundered this night f7 at the
end jaya he is here that I'm a piece of
Jim I was glad to having this bag night
f7 was ridiculous um I thought I'm okay
because of his bad King position so
maybe move like that is still
interesting Jim may be back here it's
not easy to play for black because of
his bad King I mean it at best I'm I'm
I'm okay yeah he writes good drawing
chance because of the open King yeah I
guess so yeah that's the that's the
point I agree exactly
yep that's it's it's totally okay yeah
an idea of seven was really ridiculous
but I know I remember Lee playing
playing badly in those kind of kind of
situations where it's about the whole
time I really costly I was this goodness
loses 25 points this kind of game have
to beat a couple of GM's again to get
near it okay thanks for watching